but these are the mixed signals we get
because when our you know means not like
who we we are told to do the approaching
we are taught how to win we're told to
be careful we're told all these
guidelines we're told to do all this
work and taught to put our envelope on
the line and our our our emotional
safety but then afterwards if we are
even one iota in the ROM based off your
own personal standards then we're demons
in fact and that's the hard thing that's
my bread don't want engaging the people
I want man don't approach him why not I
can block kinder and do from the safe to
my room and not get caught it feels
great
you want to mentor school after the yeah
after the no I get it but if I find out
with the next girl then I may be put on
blast on Facebook for being too push
real for being too aggressive that same
instance with the next girl can come
back to fight in their next year whether
like well I said no that a book as you
kept trying and I'm like a girl before
said keep going right so I don't know
what works for people with people so if
you tell me no I'm out I don't have to
play too much it but this that
interaction was interesting I wanted to
know your thoughts on the idea like
women like audacious man we like it but
even when you keep pushing oh I know
I've heard that many many times right
despite of what the popular thing is you
know know means knowing stuff like that
the whole time they were saying ain't no
means no I was like thank God I don't
have to care but I know some of war some
woman or for other woman because of that
you know what I mean it was a movement
that happened and that's okay but I
really feel like it does not represent
the majority or or there's a big part
there's a lot of people that are not
going in that way and they're not saying
anything because they're gonna be bashed
and they're gonna
he crashed so they don't even dare voice
their opinion so it's like now I believe
that we're passing we're kind of passing
this moment but that when this movement
started when this movement started those
who were not agreeing I might even talk
about ma'am so I was like they don't
even speak because they would get
trashed go ahead I'm grateful for the I
as well move because of the fact that it
brought to light a lot of inappropriate
behavior and a lot of like generally
normal societal behavior that wasn't
actually okay and I think it's good that
we had those conversations and that now
we're understanding that we have to
respect people's boundaries a whole lot
more the downside to that is we also
have to understand there's a cost to
things right there's no there's no
action without a reaction if I'm gonna
respect your boundaries that means I'm
we're not gonna bother you like the gone
are the days where I'm going to approach
a woman in the street that's over right
because we understand that for a lot of
people they view that as harassment I'm
not mad at it I understand that being
said I'm not gonna put myself in those
situations because some women do like it
because again like she said oh I like it
when a guy keeps trying and that's great
with her and then the next girls like oh
I can't believe you did that I'm putting
you on blast out of it so it's
interesting that those two things exist
and I'm like you can't have your cake
and eat it too there's a lot of ladies
who a woman is who complained to me like
guys don't approach them guys don't make
an effort can you blame them you can
because that's what you wanted no but
you no no no no no no no no no don't go
and start with that you know just
because there's a lot more risk if I
tempted so I'm not yeah
I'm just trying to be safe here 100% I
got evaluate everything I do to be yeah
well you know this stuff I gotta do is
course and statistics to see what are
the chances of me getting it you know
it's done and dead with and I would not
recommend it to any guy either because
the fact that we recognize that there is
that risk it's it's a self-preservation
thing and I think it's almost a little
bit arrogant to think that men are gonna
put their emotional safety on the line
by one approaching the stranger right
and then putting ourselves out there
emotionally and vulnerably you won't
expect that then you also expect
to put our careers in our personal lives
just because we don't know cuz you're
the thing you don't know how to approach
a girl on how to do it properly unless
you try and if you try that means you're
gonna fail you're gonna be awkward you
won't say some things that may be wrong
because you're trying to learn the skill
sets in order to learn how to approach
somebody but the thing is if I can't go
through that trial error period without
being rent reprimanded or losing my
career why would I try it all that's why
you have movements like mugged how where
men are going their own way because like
I'm not gonna try I'm gonna give up on
it all yeah but if you're a good guy you
shouldn't worry about that women are
label is something behavior creepy but
I'm like you do realize we have to fail
in order to be charming we have to be
uncharged in order to learn how to Beach
it's not natural doesn't come out of
nowhere we all go through that awkward
face I wasn't good at talking to lady
until I had 20 to 23 and now try to I
was approaching a lot of people before
that but it was a lot of failures it was
a lot of rejections and this isn't to
say that I think that you guys have to
suffer some nonsense just because the
fact that men want to approach you I'm
just saying you have to be as a pet
advocating that you're asking us to be
empathetic well you have to do the same
you have to give us the same courtesy by
knowing that well now we're in a
predicament where we don't know you have
to understand our point of view
so at the end of the day this is the way
society has to go forward I'm not I'm
not gonna counsel any do to approach a
girl
I'm just not and if guys want to do it
cuz they want to that's fine you take
that risk
I seem to go badly for a lot of people a
whole lot of people bro I used to
approach girls in clubs all the time of
course all the time of course I got
pictures of me like getting phone
numbers written that I used to do all
them pickup games and she liked all that
because I was trying to learn I manage
right that's the process yeah yeah to
test the waters in order to swim you
can't swim and not be wet smartest thing
I said today and it was very smart
things it was very smart so you know the
benefit of today is like yes will make
the world a lot more safer for ladies
but you know in safety it's hard to find
thrill next segment I'm just saying you
don't get on a roller coaster that goes
flat throughout the whole process
like it just go straight and I hope that
women don't come out of this thinking
that men are trying to get back at them
and that's why they're taking the stuff
it's not that it is self-preservation
that's all it comes down when this
interaction happened it was one of the
best moments with yeah oh girl you did
not in this day and age girl you did not
oh and I knew you girls existed but I
was like oh yeah oh yeah I mean it does
raise an interesting discussion I think
this is a good payoff I think it's good
that we are taking away maybe there's a
bit of romance for everybody's personal
sing romance can be there now girls do
it that's it girls not do the
approaching you gotta at least initiate
you gotta at least initiate cuz then
nobody did then way all right you're
right I just want to bring that up for
you guys so let us know what you think
in the comments below we want to hear
your opinions on this topic would you
approach a girl wait ladies do you want
to be approached do you feel bad about
the fact that no it's on you now ladies
but we want to hear the penis because
not everybody you know we do but I'm
just saying it's on you that's it peace
risky especially today's climate as a
man I would never tell anybody
yeah you have to be sensitive to that
that's what I mean I make an effort
nowadays to understand what will come
from regards to you know men are being
too pushy so when I rejected loudly it's
because I deal with hundreds of dudes
pushing on you I get that you know you
should nobody should have to be accosted
by many many men all throughout the
night
I'd be expected to be quite a hundred
percent get that but also understand
where we come from or what we have to
deal with we do you do mom say
[Music]
come on out here someone out here
Oh
looking like a UK inner-city gang member
oh you got the tracksuit at everything I
do respect the doctors you wear my
country's colors yeah I gotta give you a
bit of love what you figured that you
look like muscle last time I approached
a girl like in person it would probably
be like four years ago
look just before the I use wall movement
started really yeah last time I
approached a girl
[Laughter]
this man was about to pull out photo
books to remember when he did that
oh I know the last time I approached the
girl was two days ago I would I wanted a
double cheeseburger I approached her
other Hey how's that girl you good yeah
can I get a double cheeseburger you sent
that money on the on the table
and your life I'd like your services no
I just want a bath oh that's good